[VIDEO GAME BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Our
next lab on Qwiklabs
is Google Cloud
Datalab Qwik Start.
Cloud Datalab is an interactive
data analysis and machine
learning environment designed
for Google Cloud Platform.
You can use it to explore,
analyze, transform,
and visualize your
data interactively,
and to build machine learning
models from your data.
In the lab you'll create a
cloud Datalab instance, called
My Datalab, and use Web Preview
to access the Datalab home
page.
Then you'll create a new
notebook, run the code,
and save the notebook.
You'll use get an unget
for source control.
If you've been
following these videos
and completing these
Qwiklabs in order,
you're almost done
with this quest.
Only two more labs to
go, and the next one
is Cloud ML Engine--
Qwik Start.
This lab is part
of the Baseline--
Data, ML, and AI
quest on Qwiklabs.
Completing all the
labs in this quest
earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills.
You can show off your badge
on your resume or social media
channels.